what does it really mean to be happy you
can never be happy you could only become
happy you ever catch us sometimes unless
you're like walking around you're like
life is freaking amazing like I'm happy
Kurt Vonnegut said you should say to
yourself every time that happens like a
little Mantra like if this isn't
goodness if this isn't happiness nothing
yeah just remind yourself how awesome it
is every breath everything that you do
when you make an impact even some of the
bad stuff that happens good and it made
me think how many boats can you water
ski behind it doesn't do anything it's
called the hedonic treadmill like once
you get to a certain level it takes a
lot more you know changed followers
money impact women whatever you want to
make you have one more quanta of
Happiness right